hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
the second type of opposition that
Aristotle distinguishes in categories
book 10 is what we call contrariness or
contraries patent on TIA
this is a stronger form of opposition
than just being opposed to each other
this is when things really are contrary
opposites you could say in a very
rigorous sense of the term and Aristotle
wants to stress to us that these terms
are not correlative to each other
correlation was the the first form of
opposition that he points out and he
says look when you have terms like good
or bad or black and white it's not as if
the good is the good of the bad where it
has its meaning in relation to the bad
and lacking the bad there's no sense of
goodness as a matter of fact you could
imagine a world in which everything was
indeed completely good whether you can
imagine a world that's totally bad
probably not given some of the other
things that Aristotle says about badness
but you can certainly imagine a world
that in which everything is totally good
so good and bad are not terms like
double in half or it's use another
example master and servant or father and
son that he has put under the category
of relation till prose P instead these
are opposed to each other bad is the
opposite of good good is the opposite of
bad and this is a fundamental part of
Aristotle's metaphysical schema so
somebody may object well you know you
can't know goodness without knowing
badness Aristotle doesn't actually think
that and I should point out here as well
that the the type of opposition that is
involved in contrariness is also
different
Aristotle will point out then the third
form of opposition which is that between
hexes and strengthes or positive and
privation but we'll talk about that a
little bit later it's also not the same
thing as affirmation kind of fascist and
denial oppo fascist because those have
to do with with language and this has to
do with the qualities the the things
that we can say are in a thing and that
we can use terms to predicate of a a
thing so that's an important point now
what we really want to get to talking
about here is this interesting
discussion about intermediaries and not
having intermediaries and that's going
to have to do with the kinds of
contrariness that we're seeing in
certain terms and in certain subjects so
Aristotle will say that some contraries
are naturally found in their subjects
what does he mean by that he means that
a subject a given subject he has to have
either this one or that one and there
are many subjects that don't have that
so let's take instead of using the
health and disease example let's start
with the first example that might be
more illuminating because it's a little
bit simpler numbers right numbers
according to Aristotle and put aside
what we know about modern mathematics
with square roots and you know imaginary
numbers and stuff like that Aristotle
says that numbers must either be even or
odd one or the other and you might say
wait a second what about zero well
Aristotle didn't Hansy row that came in
mathematics later on from Indian
mathematics long after Aristotle's time
so if we if we go by the understanding
of number that Aristotle has at the time
you know what we can call the cardinal
numbers he's actually right either even
or on one or the other
and you know if a number were to change
I suppose which numbers themselves can't
for yours I would have to go from being
even to being odd or odd to being even
and it's either one of the other now
let's take something that actually does
change Aristotle talks about health and
disease numbers don't have health and
disease right just as bodies don't have
evenness or oddness I except insofar as
you're counting them or something like
that but bodies living bodies are either
healthy or diseased and Aristotle says
it's either one or the other now you
know you could object him and say well
perhaps it's healthy in this respect but
diseased in this respect okay now you're
bringing in qualifications and you're
going a little bit beyond the discussion
that he is engaging in he's talking
about overall overall a body is healthy
or a body is diseased you might say well
isn't there like a continuum between
them Aristotle says look health is when
the body is all properly functioning and
we could you know lay down some probably
fairly arbitrary limits about everything
on this side counts is healthy
everything on this side counts as
disease and we could say okay more
healthy or more disease but there's a
dividing line between the two of them
and at a certain point you cross over
into being disease or you cross back
into being healthy so you're either one
or the other now other things like a
piece of chalk neither healthy nor
diseased we might we might say other
things about that like straight or bent
right that's another example of that
sort that Aristotle uses so he says
there are no intermediaries for these
there you know when it comes to numbers
there's nothing in between odd and even
right when it comes between when it
comes to bodies and living tissues
either they're healthy or they're
diseased when it comes to objects either
they're straight or they're crooked pick
one or pick the other it gets much more
interesting when we get to the ones
Aristotle says contraries that do have
intermediates
so what would be some some examples of
those I put several of the ones that he
uses up on the board he talks for
example about colors and he uses this
quite frequently here in the categories
and on this we actually have some other
texts that that give us a bit more
information about this
Aristotle sees black and white as
existing on a spectrum where black is at
one end and white is at the other and
they are opposites to each other now
bodies can be black or they can be white
you know for example this chalk is white
and although this shirt is not you know
black it's actually a dark blue let's
just pretend it's black for a moment
because I could have put on a black
shirt today or a great example this
recording device is indeed black now
there's no internal necessity that says
that for example this recording device
must be black as a matter of fact it
could come in whatever color we want
because it's plastic and we can dye it
whatever color the dyes on the other
hand the substances that we use for
dyeing they are that particular color
and if we think about not you know the
sort of chemical things that we do today
which are very sophisticated but we
think about the dyes that and
pigmentations that they would have had
available at the time you know if you
grind up lapis lazuli for blue your it's
just going to be blue and that's it
that's not going to be a different color
if you grind up ochre for a brownish or
yellowish that's going to be that color
if you you know take shellfish and
extract the purple dye from them so you
can dye your your tunic purple that's
that color right if you wash your tunic
so that it becomes white dazzlingly
whites you know as white as we could get
at that time that's it
and the chalk itself presumably is
naturally this color I don't really know
when it comes to truck most of the track
that I've seen is white nice dim that
the other stuff is dyed but black and
white exist on a continuum nothing needs
to be necessarily black or white unless
it's that sort of thing that
automatically hands that color and we'll
talk about that in a moment and then
there's an entire spectrum in between
intermediaries so we could talk about an
intermediary where it's partly black and
partly white like grey or we could talk
about other colors and this is how
Aristotle conceives of color working in
for example on cents and the sensible or
in on the soul yellow would be an
example of another color red you know
green and we could go on and on and on
about this sort of thing what about
other things good versus bad okay so
here Aristotle says we don't really have
a middling term we just say neither good
nor bad but it's it's not the case that
for any given person they are
necessarily either good or bad they
could be somewhere in the middle and
this is in fact how Aristotle conceived
of ethics working you know it's we try
to steer ourselves away from the bad and
toward the good and we try to steer
other people like children that were in
charge of in similar ways just versus
unjust it's also possible to be neither
just nor unjust in a sense of not you
know having the virtue of justice or the
vice of injustice but it's being
somewhere in between an aerosol so
sometimes we have a word for this
sometimes with the make up words for
this sort of thing another one that he
gives is an example of you know one of
these that's on a continuum and has
intermediaries coldness versus heat
right you could say well look either
something is cold or it or it's hot it's
either one or the other no there's
lukewarm isn't it right and so there's
there's a a set of intermediaries that
are possible
now Aristotle says something else that
that's very interesting about this a
little bit further on when he's talking
about intermediaries he says when
contraries have no intermediate like the
case of health or sickness we saw that
the one or the other must ever be
present in the subject in which they are
naturally found or of which they will
serve as the predicate so you know odd
and even are naturally found or service
predicates in numbers but do not you
know do that with with a articles of
clothing except in a derivative sense
that we've already talked about in the
quantity chapter he says where this
necessity of team those terms could have
no intermediates health and disease odd
and even we're mentioned as examples but
we're contraries have an intermediate no
such necessity obtains it is not every
subject that may be receptive of black
and white that must therefore be black
or be white the fact that something
could be black or could be white doesn't
mean that it has to be either black or
white but if something can admit of
health or disease then it must admit of
one or the other and there is no middle
ground now it goes on a little bit
further and he says you gives two
examples that are particularly
interesting with respect to color and
with respect to heat so he says an
exception must be made were one contrary
naturally in here's where it's naturally
found in that that thing right where it
is present you could say and he gives
examples like fire to be hot is the
nature of fire so although in other
bodies there could be a gradation and of
course you know we can talk about one
fire being hotter than another fire a
fire has to be hot according to
Aristotle or if there's no fire that's
part of the nature of the the fiery
thing likewise he says it's the nature
of snow to be white presumably if you
the nature snow to be cold
- as well but its nature snow to be
white in such cases one of the
contraries needs must be definitely
present not one or the other in things
it's out of the question that fire
should be cold or that snow should be
black and of course you could object
well wait a second
what about yellow snow you know well
yellow snow presumably is snow that has
an admixture of something else that is
making it yellow or what about red snow
you know we get kool-aid and we sprinkle
it on the snow maybe writing our name or
something like that okay
the kool-aid is red the snow is actually
white yes but what about black ice where
the snow gets packed down at the tops of
mountains and that eventually becomes
you know this is very dark thing which
by the way is the real meaning of black
ice it's it's not what people in the
south started talking about as ice a
black black ice is actually what it
found at the tops of say the Alps for
example well what's going on there it's
not that the snow itself is becoming
black it's it's being transformed into
something different presumably but these
objections can be handled pretty easily
the basic idea is that there are certain
things that are automatically going to
have a quality if we wanted to use
another example of this you know
something that's quite similar to the
color range that Aristotle talks about
taste right
some things are sweet and sweet is that
one extreme bitter is at another extreme
and then we have all sorts of things in
between Aristotle actually distinguishes
eight fundamental flavor profiles the
fattier the oily is closer to the sweet
you know the salty is closer to the
bitter there are some things that are
bitter by their very nature and there
are some things that are sweet by their
very composition so you know to talk
about bitter sugar Arizona that's really
nonsensical it's not going to have that
property you could add something else to
the sugar like almond extract or orange
peel to give it some bitterness right
but it's not going to be bitter by
itself so some quoi some some of these
opposed qualities admit of
intermediaries some of them don't we've
seen now what the reasons for that are
in Aristotle and this is a fundamental
type of opposition for Aristotle